en turquie toujours manifestation hier
après la publication par charlie hebdo
des caricatures de mahomet un
rassemblement dans le quartier fatigue
istanbul entre pancartes et slogans
hostiles à la france et au journal
satirique les manifestants ont critiqué
également le président emmanuel macron
pour son implication notamment aux côtés
de la grèce en méditerranée orientale
écoutez ces réactions manifestants le
français macron paiera un prix très
élevé à la fois pour ses impertinences
dans l'est de la méditerranée et pour ce
soutien aux insultes contre l'islam en
utilisant la liberté de la presse comme
excuse charlie hebdo fait partie d'un
projet plus large avec la mairie qui
serait l'angleterre et la france et
certains régimes arabes tous ensemble
menant des attaques contre le monde
islamique et notre région dans les
domaines militaires économiques
politiques diplomatiques culturels
psychologique et médiatique
développement technologique et
médiatique au monde a accouché il ya une
attaque consciente de la part de
certaines personnes pour propager
l'islamophobie
mais nous ne pourrons jamais l'accepter
parce que la religion musulmane et ses
valeurs sont sacrés